[Music]
all right let's go out to St Louis
Missouri and talk to kayn what's up
kayin hi Dr John what's
happening oh your classic catchphrase is
partying so I guess you could say
partying oh that means not good at
all no no the sun is shining it's a it's
a great day oh no you've gone to weather
to make your feel good it must be really
bad what happened what's up um well I'm
I'm currently about um I guess time
frame wise I'm about one month in from
um discovering that my husband of 11
years uh was cheating ah man I'm so
sorry yeah and um I've I've got a kind
of multi prong question here so just
bear with me um but I think the big
biggest thing is just how do I process
the grief of that betrayal yeah um how
do I cope with the continue dishonesty
um in the the days following um you know
we're as I said a month out and um there
continues to
be um you know lies and
inconsistencies and some gaslighting in
my
opinion um are there any kids
involved yeah there is we have three
three daughters oh
boy
and
unfortunately he's also a part of a
family business um with my side of the
family which makes this a little bit
more
complicated because there seems to be a
little bit more um stake involved for
other you know family members and I'm
struggling a little bit with the lack of
family support from ones that I had
expected it to come
from um but ultimately um again the sun
is shining right and there's always a
new day hold on hold let's don't do that
let's don't do that I don't want to just
blow past how devastating this is and
you've added a couple layers um often
when we think yeah when we think about
cheating we think about like this very
very intimate personal betrayal
right but we often don't realize until
it's upon
us that our whole world is
exploded down to who makes who makes
lunches for the kids and who's going to
drive them and how do we switch off to
in your
case I thought my dad would be on my
side on this deal or I thought my
brother you know what I mean so I mean
for you you're losing everything
right yes that's feel like so the sun
might be shining and I I appreciate the
sentiment right but it is raining all
over your your
life right and that's okay trying well
trying is good but I don't want you to
gloss over it because your body's going
to continue to solve
for the shenanigans that is everything
right now yeah there's a lot of
craziness yes yes um she understatement
what happen in in your marriage what
happened I I don't really know when I've
asked him about the why
um I mean because initially in the first
week that was just why you know my only
thought was just why why why why this
over us you know why did you pick this
over and over over
us um you know and he says it was for
excitement um he felt like I didn't want
him around anymore M um we stopped
saying we loved each other I guess and
is what he said
I I don't really feel that though I mean
were we in a season of life where we
were disconnected certainly we have
three young very very young
kids um you know and you know we were in
the day-to-day hustle and the grind but
we were still communicating and
I mean I guess I couldn't have been more
shocked I felt like he had been living a
double
life um so you're speaking as though you
felt these things in the past tense and
then you got some new information to
realize oh he wasn't living a double
life you were just a terrible terrible
person to be married to and all of this
makes sense
now I've had a month
to how I I process some of it so I think
that's helped me realize that yeah
you probably were a little shady you
know for a while since you've been doing
this you know for quite some
time um I believe he was doing it longer
than he says but I've got no proof of
that and honestly it probably doesn't
matter anyway it's it's done
now um did you move out
no I I asked him to give me some time
and space while we kind of figured
things out and we are working with a a
marriage counselor we do have different
goals um with that marriage counselor um
he wants to try to make it work I would
like to you know move past this so that
we
can uh you know just co-parent
effectively and not you know traumatize
our our children um you know and be
emotionally mature
adults I can't tell if you're in a State
of
Shock or if you have settled because
your your affect is is not congruous
with the words you're
using um does well I probably trying to
do the steps that feel right that I know
should should be
okay you know the things that I should
do um but I mean there is a lot of shock
certainly okay um and I think I'm just
trying to process it you know dayt
day um but I'm trying to be the most
logical um I mean that's just my nature
I'm Type A I'm I'm kind of a planner
anyway so my fear is you are you have
sealed up the um pressure relief valves
so tight so that you can make what you
think in the moment is a rational
decision that you
implode or really
explode um have you said out loud I'm
not going to be your wife anymore you
took this from us and so now I'm going
to take control of my life moving
forward have you said those words out
loud no not to that effect I mean not
not that
specifically um but I've I've said you
know here's the I've set boundaries in
place for these are the times when you
need to be at the house so that you
can the the kids need to see you um
obviously we know we still need hope
need help around the home we we have a
very very little one um at home he may
need to hire that
help cuz what he did was he made some
choices they're going to have some
significant consequences both because he
lost his
family and he lost um the picture he
lost he lost everything and it's going
to come with some significant financial
consequences
and in my my fear is in an effort to
make make everything rational and simple
and
still you're going to end up getting
dragged underwater because things are
not still the waters you're in the
middle of a
hurricane and so when you're in the
middle of a hurricane often I me let me
just say this way unless it's something
I specifically have trained for so for
instance if somebody's um comes running
into the office right now and says so
and so's um on top of the building about
to kill thems I've trained for that I
know what that I I know the protocol
there um other than that like or in in
similar situations Bonker situations
like that other than that if somebody
was to come hurt my wife let's
say I will Outsource Outsource my
rational decision making to an attorney
and to the police department and to a
couple of close friends and colleagues
that I have um High trust in
because if I don't honor those feelings
in that
season my body's going to
implode and my kids are going to think
I'm insane and they're going to think
they're
insane see what I'm saying right it's
almost like you're trying to keep
everything so cool so cool so cool and
everything inside your guts knows this
is not
cool what's happening with this family
business
uh well he works with my father and why
hasn't your father thrown him out and
fired him
immediately because it's coming on their
busy time of year uh where it's
not uh I guess it wouldn't be at you
know his best interest to do that right
now um you know what comes before the
best interest of my daughter nothing
right right I no
things right
yeah I hope you sit in how disgusting
that is and don't wallpaper over that
too that's the second most important man
of your life that's let you down and I
would tell that to his face if he was
standing right here I don't care how
busy whatever crap season coming
up right I could care
less I I I agree I mean I know that on
this yes that's what it looks like um
and
like that that's what it is yeah I I
know what kind of business do they
run um
agriculture so they they Farm
together I just can't
imagine cannot
imagine my daughter having three baby
girls
and her husband cheating on her a
bunch then clocking in for work what's
up man well John if you want to feel um
I guess even more confused um add this
to the dynamic um my fathers told me
that he doesn't believe it was cheating
because it was not
physical because it was txting um there
was a lot of conversations had over
um um different social media platforms
and different apps yeah so in my dad's
standpoint he doesn't agree that it was
physical and when I explain to him that
the marriage counselor has validated my
thoughts that yes it is
cheating
um uh our marriage counselor um is a a
christian-based counselor and actually
explains it in the Bible you
know um I hey I I don't care if you were
seeing like an a Satanist right they
would agree that this isid moral right
your moral compass knows better it is
super
rare I don't have any data on this okay
so whatever but it is rare that somebody
has
multiple engagements with
people that start sending photos and
there's nothing
else very
rare and you know that I I know
that right I it's just it's dishonest I
mean the the and and that's what I've
explained to my father and you know I
mean at the end of the day your father
has cashed out your father cashed out
right thank you he chose his bro over
his
daughter thank you for validating that
that means a lot I hate that for
you cuz when your husband does you wrong
there should be that one guy left in
your
corner and um I've never experienced
this but I've just sat with enough
sexual assault victims over
time that they tell me one of the most
important things is when they tell their
story finally that the first person they
tell them believes
them and one step removed from sexual
assault this violation that somebody
took something from me the next step is
somebody took something from you
somebody took your family away cuz they
just need some excitement wanted to feel
alive a little
bit and Kaylin you just weren't doing
your part I know you're raising those
three babies but you just you know kind
of weren't pulling your weight around
here making me feel
special
and you sat down with your dad and he
looked at you and said I don't believe
you I believe that
guy and I've never been in your shoes
but from the narratives I've heard from
sitting with countless women in that
situation I'm
sorry the question you have to live with
I mean live into is what are you going
to do
next and it sounds like the two men that
should have been there for you chose
each other and chose deception and chose
dishonesty and by doing so they chose to
no longer be in relationship with
you and that's going to hurt hurt hurt
hurt hurt it it does and I think my
logical brain knows that the only way
forward is divorce I I don't see how we
can rebuild the trust the
respect it's possible you can rebuild it
but you got to tell the truth first and
he's not so far that hasn't happened
correct and and
that's
yeah um
and it's going to be hard it's going to
get harder before it gets any easier I
know that but I'm the lack of family
support makes it more there's no family
support and let's be real real like
brass haacks being a single mom with
three girls three little kids is a
nightmare
financially like just day to day it's
challeng yeah it'll be challenging yeah
yep yeah and that listen to me carefully
you've got to have a group of women that
will walk alongside you during
this I wish that would be your family
but it sounds like it's
not I have some family members that that
will um my mom's been really supportive
but that's hard for their marriage
because she is still married to well
they're grownups that's that's for them
to deal with that's not for you no right
yeah right but you also need a couple of
women in your life that are not um your
best
buddies also you're 30 days out and I
think a separation is good I don't think
this has to end in divorce doesn't have
to they can if you want it
to um you're not
crazy but I feel crazy sometimes I know
because the people around you are
gaslighting you so bad you can't see
straight yeah
right if I send naked pictures to
somebody else or vice versa that's
cheating on my wife period period it
just is just
is yep and nobody wants to see naked
pictures of me still I put that out
there but if I do that as cheating and
anybody tells you otherwise is just
trying to has ulterior
motives yep I I
age I hate this for you hate this for
you I hate this for you I hate this for
you the hard part on calls like this
kayin is there's no
easy just go do these three
things you're doing the right things
right now you're meeting with a
counselor you're talking to your mom who
trusts you and believes you it sounds
like you need to get a couple of women
that you say hey I need to meet with
y'all once a week every
Monday you need to sit down with your
analytical brain and be very clear about
the financial needs that you need right
now in your
home and that could include someone to
help out with the kids that could
include somebody to help out with um
like housework and things like that and
your husband gets to pick up that
Tab and you're going to have to explore
the really uncomfortable like everything
in your life got dumped over life change
of to get a job going to find work
figuring out what that means and what
that looks like and how that's going to
work out in your town and all like your
qualifications all
that here's the the challenge with an
analytical brain the approach you're
taking there's a challenge with an over
emotional right it's just ah and it's
just hard to even make a rational Choice
you've hit the hit the pendulum so far
the other
way the hard part with a rational choice
is you don't feel it
and you try to just make sure
everything's smooth which without
meaning to you end up conceding to
things for the sake of Peace you keep
this Peacekeeper role which you've
probably had for a long time and you
just try to get to the next quick second
in the next 30 minutes and the next 30
minutes which is life with three little
kids that's also a mindset they've
studied mind uh folks with poverty
mindset they've studied folks with a
wealth mindset those who can look past
tomorrow
that's how you begin to separate
yourself financially and if I'm worried
about where my next meal comes from and
my next meal comes from I'm always just
worried about where my next meal is
coming from not when I start worrying
about where my grandkid meals are going
to come from and so you're going to have
to get some people with you to help you
feel your way through this and not just
try to logic your way through it and
logic your way through it there's going
to be some moments when you have to
Outsource your logic to an attorney to a
therapist what do I do next next and
they're going to say you need to have
this hard conversation or that hard
conversation and you're going to have to
spend some time maybe you write yourself
letters maybe you started journaling I
I'd really strongly recommend that
actually and make it a daily practice
I'm going to write down how I
feel because if you bottle that up like
a nuclear reactor your daughters are
going to feel it you're going to feel it
everyone around you will feel it and
you're going to be trying to be cool as
a cucumber that's just a recipe for
combustion
and people with a rational analytical
mind are always trying to get things
back to the way they
were need to get things I need to get
this divorce over so that everything can
be smooth I just need to get this over
so everything can be smooth I just need
to tell this have this one conversation
and give this um dollar amount that I
need over so that everything can be
smooth there is no going back to the way
things were everything's different now
everything's different
now and husband if you're watching this
the only only chance you have at
reconciliation and building something
new is you got to tell the truth all of
it all of it starting now and dads if
your daughters come to
you believe
them